nous donner sa version des faits sur
cette histoire qui a fait énormément
parler petit récap et il s'appelle anis
anis il sera avec nous à quoi dans un
instant c'est parti
de 800000 personnes sur Instagram Aqua
babe se fait connaître en révélant de
nombreux dossiers sur les célébrités et
les stars de la télé-réalité moi à part
apporter des preuves et des éléments je
fais rien de mal mais en 2018 le jeune
homme charge un autre blogueur Jeremstar
à son nom est alors entaché dans un
sombre scandale le Jeremstar gate qui
lui vaut d’être menacé et lui fait vivre
un véritable calvaire j'ai jamais été
autant harcelé sur les réseaux sociaux
que cette année qui vient de s'écouler
Jeremstar décide alors de porter plainte
contre Aqua babe qu'il juge responsable
un blocage du nom d'Aquaba qui s'est mis
à balancer tout et n'importe quoi sur
moi pour pour exister pour diffamation
le blogueur star acabe livre sa version
des faits ce soir dans T
est avec nous qui regardait ses lunettes
bonsoir oui j'ai gardé mes lunettes
parce que j'ai un énorme complexe c'est
une discerne donc flemme d'avoir des
trucs mais si depuis que je suis tout
petit j'ai de la salle j'ai 24 ans 24
ans mais je vois tu es un visage regarde
la peau même lui qui a une belle peau à
côté ben on dirait que
non non tu passes bien franchement tu
passes de maison au mieux est-ce que tu
peux expliquer à nos téléspectateurs
c'est quoi ton métier alors je suis
blogueur scooper alors j'apporte des
exclusivités sur Instagram donc et ça ça
gagne ça gagne bien ouais ça marche bien
tu as 800000 followers sur insta ça
marche bien ça veut dire ouais toi tu
comment tu gagnes ta vie en fait que
pour que les gens comprennent alors moi
je vais être placement de produit comme
tout le monde avec des agences etc c'est
un indépendant donc c'est les
prestataires qui viennent eux-mêmes me
contacter sur WhatsApp et je réponds
directement quoi c'est moi qui fait le
tri d'accord et donc quoi il te paye
pour ouais pour pour être pour de la pub
pour de la pub et donc comme tu es comme
tu es très suivi et toi tu dis par
exemple Bernard Montiel a montré son
kiki au théâtre
ouais mais il faut des preuves il faut
des preuves bien sûr alors comment tu
fais pour avoir tes preuves tout ça
comment se fait un réseau tu as quoi tu
as des taupe ouais j'ai beaucoup de
taupe c'est vrai est-ce que tu peux nous
révéler qui la taupe ici s'il te plaît
un peu partout
ils contactent sur Instagram
j'ai fait une espèce de petite catégorie
où tu cliques ça espèce de petit
formulaire ou tu as juste à cliquer sur
dans mes DM pour si tu as un scoop ou si
tu as une question donc c'est super
simple genre j'ai vu Daniel Moreau en
short aux formules
donc aujourd'hui vous avez tout le monde
n'est pas paradis alors si tu veux nous
parler de ça mais juste avant
ça concerne Jeremstar a totalement tu as
vu son passage sur notre plateau et tu
nous as demandé un droit de réponse et
ici je vous dis on donne toujours les
droits de réponse et tous les droits de
réponse sont toujours les bienvenues
voilà on garde tout de suite ce qu'il
avait dit tu vas nous répondre à ça et
une histoire en fait de quelqu'un que je
ne connaissais ni d'avenir d'Adam un
blogueur du nom d'Aquaba qui s'est mis à
balancer tout et n'importe quoi sur moi
pour pour exister et donc vous savez
comment vont les réseaux sociaux ça va
très vite on est dans l'air c'est plus
balance ton peur c'est balance tout et
n'importe quoi sur n'importe qui pour
exister vous étiez pote ou pas du tout
non pas du tout pas du tout je ne le
connaissais même pas donc je me suis
retrouvé du jour au lendemain avoir ma
gueule avec des noms gravissimes et
vas-y que j'étais complice de viol et
que j'étais pédophiles et compagnie donc
après bah ça s'emballe ça va très vite
sur les réseaux
un gamin était manipulé par un paparazzi
pour déposer plein de contre moi alors
que je ne l'avais jamais vu
alors donc qu'est-ce que tu voulais
répondre tout ce qui dit c'est c'est des
informations sur lui ouais totalement
alors moi quand j'ai lancé le Jerem
Stargate de base c'était une cause noble
j'ai jamais voulu créer du buzz sur lui
parce que bon gratter du buzz sur
Jeremstar surtout une fois comme ça
pourquoi tu as fait ça alors de base
c'est parti d'un vol de scoop il m'a
volé mon scoop concernant les anges et
de là on se coupe on s'est arrangeant
alors on se trouve concernant les gens
c'était chanai Adrien aperçu
s'embrassé sorti de voiture
c'était une excuse de dingue parce que
une sorte de Daniel Moreau
mais non parce que à cette époque là il
y avait pas encore de paparazade
des vidéos de tournage j'en avais pas tu
vois
et donc il t'a volé
je vais le défoncer alors comment il a
volé il a sorti avant vous c'est ça non
pas du tout il est venu m'enregistrer la
vidéo sur snap donc je voyais son nom
d'utilisateur
donc du coup il est venu enregistrer
comme ça gratos quoi ouais et le
lendemain
il y a une différence entre reprendre un
article et faire un article en barrant
sa source là il avait clairement mis un
gros stylo en mettant source j'ai rien
fait star quoi donc de là moi j'avais
son numéro de téléphone je les joins je
me dis c'est quoi cet article je viens
de voir ta sortie apparemment une exclu
sauf que je l'ai sorti avant toi il m'a
bloqué et c'est là que la guerre a
commencé il m'a bloqué il m'a ignoré si
tu veux mais qu'est-ce que je vais le
calculer et donc ouais tu es donc tu
t'es dit bah j'ai pris mon téléphone bon
après on va pas se mentir j'ai j'avais
18 ans j'ai parlé super mal avec ma
bouche je le reconnais
alors à part Benjamin Castaldi qui parle
avec ses fesses tout le monde parle avec
sa bouche
non mais franchement je regrette je
regrette là des trucs que tu fais ou pas
moi j'ai vu que tu as mis des trucs sur
moi aussi sur gilbertez tu sais que
parfois lui voilà lui Gilles je te le
dis parce que moi j'en ai rien à [__]
je te dis la vérité franchement moi je
dis tu peux chercher moi j'ai rien moi
j'ai rien je suis un peu beau gosse
voilà
tu peux le dire toutes les semaines si
tu veux moi ça les limites ça me fait
plaisir non mais c'est vrai bon tu m'as
fait moi tu m'as fait Ken tout Paris ça
me fait plaisir franchement à la limite
continue voilà mais Gilles franchement
je te le dis parce que est-ce que est-ce
que ça te fait de la peine quand tu vois
que tu peux faire du mal parce que
Gilles je crois que toi ça t'a causé
beaucoup de problèmes bien sûr bien sûr
d'autant que c'est quelqu'un avec qui on
a travaillé ici sur des sujets donc
voilà ça moi j'ai raté une information
j'ai pas cherché à vous descendre
franchement je non j'ai rien contre vous
j'ai juste relayer
tu sors une information est-ce que tu te
dis ça peut faire des gros embrouilles
ou pas du tout
ouais
ça lui a fait des gros problèmes mais
c'est pas mon but c'est pas ton but ah
du tout mais plus tu sors des grosses
coupes plus tu prends de l'argent ou pas
du tout
non je comprenne le pas forcément alors
pas du tout les abonnés ouais je prends
des abonnés
bien le bail aussi tu connais bien quoi
alors qu'est-ce que tu dis toi je pense
que enfin on en a déjà parlé tous les
deux je pense que il y a une espèce de
course à l'info et course au buzz et que
malheureusement je pense que tu prends
des chemins qui effectivement vont faire
parler parce que oui c'est des affaires
qui intéressent l'infidélité les
tromperies les couples voilà mais que ça
fait beaucoup de mal aux gens que c'est
dangereux et que ça peut être dangereux
pour toi aussi et donc que c'est pas
bien chant entièrement de l'accord avec
toi après bon on entend foot surtout à
quoi babe dans des histoires de
polémique mais je fais pas que ça sors
des infos tournages genre des aperçu à
la Gossip Girl je fais pas que du trash
certes des fois je mets la main c'est
quoi ton kiffe à quoi ben tu as envie de
faire quoi plus tard parce que tu étais
hyper jeune tu as envie de continuer
là-dessus tu as envie de faire ouais
développer un
big réseau franchement devenir le Tiem
zizi français pourquoi pas ouais
tu as envie de faire de du chat j'ai
pété
non franchement là l'intelligence
artificielle vous avez été accusé et je
crois condamné de cyber-harcèlement
aussi quand même ça non j'ai jamais
testé alors c'est faux c'est faux je
tiens à le dire parce que beaucoup
mentir me concernant j'ai été condamné
apparemment pour diffamation et
également insultes homophobe insultes
parce que j'ai très mal avec ma bouche
je le reconnais vous regrettez bien sûr
les insultes n'avaient pas du tout
homophobe mais bien sûr sachant que
moi-même je suis homo l'intérêt un petit
peu voilà quoi mais concernant la
diffamation c'est totalement faux
sachant que moi mes preuves ont été
malheureusement pas reçu face à la
justice parce qu'ils vont clairement dit
c'est des enregistrements illégal à son
insu donc vous n'avez jamais été
condamné vous dites vous mais si
il précise pas pourquoi j'ai été
condamné sur les mots
parfois tu te dis pas c'est du
harcèlement qu'il y a des mecs qui vont
mal finir parce que il y en a qui sont
solides tu vois voilà mais je sais que
tu vois agile je te dis il était au bout
de sa vie et puis il y en a qui sont
bien bien est-ce que tu te dis ça ou
bien tu te dis non tu vois seulement
c'est un grand mot quand même pour moi
harceler la personne tous les jours tous
les jours tous les jours pour moi et
après tu ouais pour moi c'est pas
harceler quelqu'un c'est juste informé
j'entends ce que vous dites mais vous
dites en fait je m'en lave les mains
c'est un peu Ponce Pilate je me lave les
mains mais mais en fait quand vous
balancez une information
je sais pas comment d'ailleurs vous
décidez qu'elle est importante ou pas et
après vous savez bien que ça va générer
des gens sur votre réseau qui vont
peut-être éventuellement aller
absolument
people après bon j'ai pas capté
la presse à scandale je une nouvelle
presse entre guillemets digital sur
Instagram faut dire faut essayer de
dissocier le personnage c'est à dire moi
et le fait que je suis quand même une
presse parce que bon certes je suis pas
encore reconnu en tant que presque
officielle je suis pas sûr que tu
aimerais passer dans un truc plus comme
ça plus conventionnel ou pas ouais bien
sûr ouais donc oui la carte de presse
Nicolas non mais il y a un information
et
salir quelqu'un pardon moi je fais une
différence quand même de l'information
et traiter quelqu'un de pédophile
c'est-à-dire que c'est quand même
imaginez imaginez que demain on vous
traite de pédophilie ou d'autres choses
et qui a aucune raison c'est pas menti
son ami a bien été attendez mais c'est
pas votre job traiter quelqu'un de
pédophile j'ai aujourd'hui on est on est
dans une problématique il y a de plus en
plus de jeunes qui suscitent justement à
cause de fausses rumeurs sur internet ou
sur les réseaux sociaux vous devriez
être un exemple vous avez une vingtaine
d'années je suis désolé c'est pas de
l'information c'est pas du journaliste
que d'aller balancer aveuglement sur
quelqu'un des choses terribles
un proche de Jeremstar sur nos messages
Babybel parce qu'il était une belle des
champs à l'époque euh il relève sur les
réseaux des témoignages accusant ce
quinquagénaire d'avoir proposé de
manière insistante des rapports sexuels
à d'autres hommes pour certains mineurs
donc ça n'a rien à voir c'est ça
l'histoire
voilà bon mais oui ce qui est vrai non
c'est vrai qu'on critique beaucoup à
quoi mais en fait son travail c'est ni
plus ni moins que la presse people en
fait tu parles ça existe et cetera après
il y a quand même une petite différence
selon moi c'est que la presse people tu
m'as fait pécho tout le monde il faut
quand même dire la vérité aujourd'hui
concrètement la presse people elle a une
éthique c'est-à-dire qu'elle a des
limites elle va pas publier des sextape
elle m'appelle publier n'importe quoi et
là moi ce qui me fait peur peut-être que
je me trompe mais j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui le danger avec toi c'est
que il y a quelqu'un qui peut te
contacter sur les réseaux n'importe qui
qui peut dire tiens j'ai une saloperie à
balancer sur un tel une telle est-ce que
tu vérifies est-ce que sans vérifier tu
vas le publier est-ce que c'est le cas
ou pas c'est totalement faux c'est pas
parce que j'ai toujours certes j'ai une
image vraiment du mec à problème qui
surf sur des vagues de buzz etc c'est
faux c'est totalement faux moi je reçois
des éléments vraiment c'est ça craint et
ils sont jamais sortis ok Jeremstar
j'avais 18 ans j'ai sorti ça sextape
pour me venger d'accord maintenant
excusez-moi mais ressortez la sextape de
Daniel Moreau je voudrais même pas la
voir c'est sympa c'est pas sympa ça
noir et blanc c'est magnifique
non mais on va pas se mentir
sortez-moi là récemment
une affaire où j'ai sorti une sextape ou
un truc comme ça il y en a pas justement
Guillaume il pose une vraie question
quel est votre limite est-ce que vous
vous êtes dit il y a des choses vers
lesquelles je n'irai pas parce que là
moralement c'est je vais pas aller là
dessus c'est sur lesquels par exemple
les histoires de vidéos sextape etc bah
oui ça a été mon erreur mais ça tu iras
plus ça j'aurais plutôt sur ce terrain
là ça m'intéresse pas je peux en faire
tranquille alors
[Rires]
il y a plein d'autres sujets après moi
je suis pas flic hein je vais être
honnête avec vous je suis pas policier
je suis pas j'ai pas de
j'ai pas tout ça donc oui je reçois des
fois des éléments archi graves et c'est
là pour autant que j'en fais des sujets
sur insta alors Valentin voulait moi
je coconne et une
top en fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ton but c'est quoi c'est d'être le
justicier de la vérité c'est ça
moi j'apporte des informations oui et
puis je suis un espèce de Gossip Girl
2.0 sur Instagram quoi donc tu considère
pas que au final même les personnalités
publiques ont des vie privée et puis des
histoires qui les concernent
et puis on va pas attraper la veste au
Parisien ou à closer ou à donc c'est
facile de tout le temps s'en prendre à
Aquaba c'est facile genre oui c'est le
petit Aquaba il a 24 ans il est sur
Instagram donc du coup il fait chier les
gens non c'est pas vrai j'apprends des
informations c'est tout et au niveau des
taupes justement ça fonctionne comment
parce que ça c'est intéressant ça veut
dire que
ça veut dire que il a des trucs
dans les endroits où tu as envie
d'inspecter un peu tu essayes de mettre
des gens dedans ou alors est-ce que
c'est les gens qui sont dans certains
environnements par exemple qui viennent
après vers toi c'est les deux il a des
taux partout c'est les deux franchement
c'est les deux par exemple partout
partout je sais pas comment tu dis mais
je dirais un exemple je vais citer TPMP
si par exemple je veux m'intéresser aux
ktpnp et juste à mettre une story avec
le logo TPMP et les gens qui travaillent
ici vont venir parler tout seul c'est
comme ça que ça marche hein
[Applaudissements]
ils ont vu des trucs voilà mais après
voilà la dernière fois voilà il se dit
que c'est il m'avait vu en train de de
de de de bouffer le cul de Daniel ici
c'était c'était un mirage oui c'est une
question un peu trivial mais est-ce que
tu as pas peur qu'un jour il y a une
célébrité qui pète un câble et qui s'en
prennent à toi physiquement qui viennent
te casser la gueule
un rappeur
et donc là
on continue mais avec des limites par
exemple tout ce qui est touchy ou je
sais que c'est des personnes faut même
pas parler je parle pas je veux pas je
peux pas mentir je veux pas faire le
justicier ici à dire ouais moi je suis
non pas du tout j'ai limite même si on
dirait pas mais j'ai limite
merci en tout cas oui c'est un homme
parce que ça ce soir on est dans le
turfu
l'intelligence artificielle et ça ça
c'est ça il y en a de plus en plus
[Musique]
dans quelques temps tu vas voir Daniel
Moreau
[Rires]
merci en tout cas merci on va se
retrouver dans un instant les Gira tout
de suite